[Musique]
non mais c'est normal que le deuil de ma
cuisine se soit pas fait correctement
enfin je sais pas elle est morte il ya
deux ans je me pose encore tellement de
questions comme quoi par exemple bah
j'en reste qu'elle a souffert et ce
qu'elle s'est vue mourir et puisque son
corps est devenu tu vois à ça je peux
très bien alors faut juste que tu saches
un truc de toi à moi c'est que l a pas
eu un enterrement très classique c'est à
dire bah on l'a enterré nous mêmes dans
une forêt en bretagne en fait à c'était
ses dernières volontés
s'agencent ah non en fait c'est qu'on
l'avait sorti du congélo et du coup bah
on a un peu été pris de court ok bah
écoutes je n'ai pas tous les éléments
donc je vais pas de juger mais aussi tu
veux on peut voir tout ça ensemble enfin
je veux dire si ça t'aide à tourner la
page
-
quand on se lance dans huit ans d'études
pour apprendre à devenir archéologue
il n'est pas rare que l'entourage
exprime un certain doute concernant
l'utilité de ce métier on pourrait bien
sûr leur répondre que l'étude des
phénomènes sociétaux du passé permet de
comprendre certaines erreurs
fondamentales qui ont été faites par nos
prédécesseurs afin d'éviter de les
reproduire dans le présent mais bon tout
le monde sait très bien que les
politiciens n'écoute pas les
archéologues alors pour certains d'entre
nous il a fallu trouver un sens concret
à la pratique de l'archéologie et ce
sont les forces de l'ordre qui nous ont
donné un moyen d'être vraiment utile à
nos contemporains voyons ensemble
comment des archéologues spécialisée
dans la fouille des lieux funéraire
peuvent aider à résoudre des crimes
parfois mieux que les médecins légistes
[Musique]
depuis les années 80 en france il existe
une sous-discipline de l'archéologie
dévolu spécifiquement à la fouille des
structures funéraire ça s'appelle la
thanato archéologie cette nouvelle
discipline a été conceptualisée par le
préhistorien leroi gourhan avant d'être
déployé par l'équipe d'henri du des de
l'université de bordeaux le professeur
duguay est médecin et archéologue
spécialisée dans le néolithique il faut
il donc des structures bien bordélique
typique de la période qu'on appelle des
allées couvertes ce sont des sépultures
géante dont lesquels on dépose des
centaines de morts sur plusieurs
générations comme l'occupation de la
structure se fait sur plusieurs
décennies des squelettes sont bougés
intentionnellement accidentellement et
des gens viennent même récupérer des
bouts de corps qu'il sorte de la
structure pour des raisons obscures
difficile donc de restituer les
différentes étapes de l'utilisation du
tombeau pour y voir clair dans cet amas
d'ossements du des décide alors de faire
appel à ses connaissances en anatomie
humaines et en médecine légale il
s'aperçoit vite des potentialités
extraordinaires de cette
interdisciplinarité et crée alors
l'archéo anthropologie de terrain ou
thanato archéologie les principes de la
thanatologie sont simples mais efficaces
tout d'abord cette discipline exige
d'adapter les méthodes de fouilles des
structures funéraire afin de ne pas
bouger le moindre haussement du
squelette on oublie donc la pioche et
l'appel et on s'arme d'une petite ruelle
d'outils de dentiste deux pinceaux et
l'aspirateur pour évacuer les sédiments
qui seront ensuite tamisée pour
récupérer les plus fins indices une fois
le squelette enlevé de sa gangue de
terre on le photographie sous toutes les
coutures on ajoute un quadrillage pour
pouvoir relever la position des objets
dans l'espace de manière très précise
sur deux axes abscisses et ordonnées on
procède alors à un relevé millimétriques
sous forme de dessin pour conserver en
mémoire l'emplacement de chaque
ossements pour connaître la disposition
des eaux et des objets dans leur volume
on mesure également l'altimétrie grâce à
des instruments utilisés par les son et
les topographes les niveaux de chantier
mais pourquoi une telle minutie dans le
relevé des informations et bien tout
simplement parce qu'un os qui bouge de
quelques millimètres par rapport à son
emplacement anatomique logique ça
raconte beaucoup de choses quand le
corps se décompose les chairs puis les
tendons disparaissent les os du
squelette se désolidarise alors les uns
des autres et sa dislocation a lieu dans
un ordre bien précis en fonction des
conditions environnementales vous savez
donc que l'os hyoïde celui qui flotte
dans votre gorge sera l'un des premiers
à se faire la malle mais que les deux
première vertèbre cervicale prendront
tout leur temps pour se déconnecter du
crâne en observant précisément quel ça
bougeait et quel os et restait en place
malgré la décomposition vous pourrez
connaître les conditions de
l'ensevelissement et répondre à des
questions essentielles telles que quel
était l'état de décomposition du corps
au moment de son inhumation est ce que
la fosse était rempli de sédiments ou
pas dans un espace colmatée par du
sédiment les déplacements seront minimes
alors que dans un espace vide ça peut
s'éparpiller un petit peu partout du
coup si l'espace est vide mais que les
ossements reste relativement discipline
et cela signifiera que le squelette
était protégé comme lorsqu'il est mis
dans un cercueil ou une bosch vous
pouvez aussi savoir si des interventions
ont été faites sur le corps après cette
première inhumation une violation de
sépultures pour commettre un vol
d'objets ça fait des dégâts
reconnaissable que les archéologues
peuvent replacer dans la chronologie
général des événements grâce à un savoir
empirique acquis après des heures de
contacts très sensuel avec la terre les
spécialistes sont également capables de
déterminer les limites précises de la
fosse qui accueille le corps la texture
du sol change en effet à chaque
creusement de celui ci et ses variations
parfois infimes se ressentent sous la
truelle de l'archéologue expérimentés
grâce à cette discipline les arcs et au
tannat tôt log peuvent donc tirer le
maximum d'informations des sépultures
ancien leur forme leur durée
d'exploitation
la méthode de rebouchage et cetera à tel
point que ces avancées extraordinaires
été adoptés partout dans le monde par
les archéologues en l'espace de
seulement une décennie un savoir faire
qui nous vaut encore de recevoir les
meilleurs étudiants internationaux dans
le laboratoire passer à 2 bordeaux et de
paris 1 et qui nous permet aussi
d'élucider des affaires criminelles aux
côtés des meilleurs flics s'il ne reste
pas de chair mais qu'il reste des eaux
on est là pour vous or chaque année en
france on retrouve entre 200 et 400
corps dont la plupart sont à l'état de
squelette ça nous fait du boulot lors
d'actes criminels il n'est pas rare que
des meurtriers ou leurs complices essaye
de cramer le corps pour faire
disparaître les preuves mais c'est un
mauvais calcul l'archéologue funéraire
est aussi formé à l'analyse des restes
humains calcinés et sera capable
d'analyser ce que le corps a subi en
détail même si celui ci a été passé au
feu en fait le plus simple pour faire
disparaître un corps c'est de s'y
connaître en géologie et en chimie des
sols
alors si tu veux savoir où enterrer un
cadavre le mieux si tu veut dissoudre le
squelette c'est de l'intérêt dans un sol
acide parce qu'en fait non aux eaux sont
constitués principalement de carbonate
de calcium qui sont alcalin et du coup
si tu voulais d'ici août faut mettre de
l'acide dessus donc ça peut être aussi
bien du jus de citron du vinaigre très
très concentré sinon faut que tu es
beaucoup de temps devant toi d'ailleurs
petite anecdote c'est comme ça qu'on
reconnaît le calcaire sur le terrain tu
te balades avec une petite fiole d'acide
chlorhydrique et si tu aimais du glacis
dessus et que ça à bulbes assez que
bingo c'est du caca donc faut en revenir
au sol il faut un sol acide pour fortis
toutes les eaux tu vas pas t'amuser à
creuser des trous partout et mettre un
peu de bandelettes péage pour savoir si
ça si nous pas en fait t'as des indices
que tu veux trouver sur le terrain donc
tu peux t'intéresser à la roche mère
donc c'est la roche qui a sous le sol si
cette roche et siliceuses donc si c'est
pas du calcaire mais au contraire plus
du schiste ou du granit à ce moment là
tu as plus de chances que ton sol soit
assis dessus et sinon tu peux est
intéressé à la végétation cas tu donc
c'est vachement plus pratique quand même
parce qu'en fait il ya très très peu de
plantes qui supportent l'acidité du sol
c'est ce qu'on appelle des plantes
acidophiles alors c'est pas qu'elle aime
l'acidité c'est juste qu'elle l'a
supporté mieux que les autres quoi et
donc ce qui est marrant aussi c'est que
ces plantes là elles vont acidifier à
leur tour le sol donc c'est un peu une
boucle rigolote et donc parmi ces
plantes la ja le lierre il ya la
myrtille il y a
la fougère il ya les conifères en
général et donc si tu as et plante là au
dessus tu peux avoir des chances en
dessous d'avoir un sol acide et
notamment le hot doll qui me semblent
préférer c'est complètement à cause de
son nom en fait le pote sol c'est ce
qu'on trouve par exemple sous la taïga
en russie et ce à un sol qui ultra acide
et donc très peu fertile en général est
dedans on trouve à un horizon ce qu'on
appelle donc une couche constitué de
sable siliceux la plupart du temps sinon
tu peux aussi miser sur une tourbière
incident du genre avec des bruyères
dessus d'être comme ça parce que du coup
ça peut bien dissoudre le corps et puis
je trouve ça assez cinématographique
d'enterrer quelqu'un dans une tourbière
jeu parce que tu en france voilà est-ce
que ça répond à ta question du coût
depuis quelques années des archéologues
funéraires ont été intégrés à l'iss cgn
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale pour aider à
résoudre des affaires criminelles ils
sont plus précisément affilié au
département d'anthropologie hématome
morphologie qui a un logo vraiment très
rock'n'roll cela dit au passage le champ
d'action de l'archéologue auprès des
gendarmes est assez vaste d'abord en cas
de découverte d'ossements et part il
peut éclairer les enquêteurs sur
l'identité du défunt et sur la nature
des lésions sur les os en utilisant les
méthodes de l'anthropologie biologique
évidemment ça se fait en collaboration
avec les légistes mais on va pas se
mentir les légistes sont davantage
formés à l'analyse des tissus mous et
pour résoudre un meurtre on est jamais
trop nombreux à cogiter alors les
retours d'expérience des archéologues
qui manipulent des squelettes tous les
jours sans les bienvenus et puis parfois
on a une disparition un suspect un
périmètre on suspecte qu'un corps a été
planqué mais pas de cadavre or retrouvé
le corps est indispensable pour
restituer les faits et confondre les
meurtriers pour retrouver le lieu où le
cadavre a été dissimulé on peut utiliser
des chiens renifleurs ou des
archéologues en effet nous savons
reconnaître la présence de creusement et
de structures maçonné disparu en
observant seulement la variation de la
végétation de manière générale une
fausse laissera un sol meuble plus aérée
qui accueillera volontiers une
végétation abondante alors que les
structures maçonné prive les végétaux de
racines profondes et entraîne donc leur
raréfaction c'est comme ça que deux
archéologues découvrent des villes
entières rien qu en survolant la zone en
avion ceci dit une fosse avec un corps
humain dedans ne se comporte pas
toujours comme une fausse normal les jus
de décomposition ont tendance à brûler
les racines des herbes et des petites
plantes ce qui peut provoquer des
lacunes d'implantation chez certaines
espèces fragiles lorsque la topographie
du terrain le permet on peut également
retrouver les fausses grâce à
l'utilisation de géoradar ou radar à
pénétration de sol des instruments
utilisés régulièrement pour les
prospections archéologiques et dont
l'utilisation est bien moins intuitif
qu'il n'y paraît un archéo est donc
toujours le bienvenu pour les manipuler
une fois le lieu de la fosse identifier
il faut l'ouvrir pour retrouver le corps
et les indices tout autour mais
attention pas question d'y aller comme
des sauvages comme ça a été fait sur la
sphère emile louis en 2004 avec une
pelleteuse muni d'un godet a dans ce
carnage les archéologues prêtent main
forte mais en étant muni d'une
pelleteuse ago délice pour enlever des
couche fine et régulière de sédiments la
conduite de ce type d'engin nécessite un
permis mais surtout une grande
expérience de manipulation une fois le
plus gros de la terre retirée les
archéologues funéraire passer à la
fouille chine et méthodique qui leur
permettent de dégager le corps sans le
bouger mais aussi de retrouver tous les
indices associés qui permettent de
reconstituer toute une chaîne d'actions
chaque perturbations du sol et
identifier chaque manipulation du corps
ou du squelette et reconstitués afin de
restituer l'état initial de remonter
autant zéro c'est à dire à la scène de
crime originel
j'ai appelé mon thé comme c'est lui qui
a découvert le corps et puis bon tu sais
il a participé à l'enterrement tout ça
donc je me suis dit que pour est ok elle
est morte de quoi de rires
non mais c'est très bien ça a l'air
d'une mort naturelle comme ça c'est une
mort naturelle oui ça me regarde pas
elle est resté combien de temps dans le
salon
8h03 pourquoi et c'était en hiver ok
donc les insectes nécrophages on peut le
temps de se mettre dans le cadavre non
parce que quand c'est le cas les
archéologues peuvent tamiser le
sédiments autour du squelette il
retrouve les petites [ __ ] des insectes
et ils peuvent en déduire combien de
temps le cadavre a été exposé à l'air
libre et même la saison de la mort mais
c'est trop cool ouais bon et donc tout
de suite après vous étalez l'intégrer
dans la forêt quoi alors non on apprend
la mise au congélo alliel fallait pas
c'est à dire que la congélation ça
fragilise la structure osseuse donc ça
laisse des stigmates très clairement
identifiable au moins à l'échelle
microscopique or un cadavre qui passe
par un congélateur ben ça fait pas trop
mort naturelle on n'avait pas pensé à ça
rassurez moi vous l'avez pas mise au
congélateur puis sorti du congélateur et
ce plusieurs fois de suite au moins sous
ce serait beaucoup plus grave a
évidemment pour congés jamais de viande
qui a déjà été congelé c'est un coup à
saper la mort quand on en mange alors
voilà on l'a pas fait on l'a pas fait
plus de trois fois
on compte a dit aussi que le chien avait
bouffé un morceau ou
[Musique]
les archéologues récolte des indices
permettant de remonter jusqu'à
l'identité des meurtriers pendant la
fouille souvenez-vous les archéologues
sont des experts lorsqu'il s'agit de
retrouver les bords de la fosse or sur
les parois de la fosse se trouve très
souvent des traces de peinture laissé
par l'apel utilisé pour creuser le trou
celle ci est alors soigneusement
prélevés et analysés et il est possible
de remonter à la pelle d'origine par
comparaison avec celle des suspects
surtout si elle a été achetée récemment
les premiers coups dans le sol les
seront facilement des traces de peinture
un autre aspect fondamental de
l'archéologie est exploité par la
gendarmerie pour améliorer leurs
connaissances pour mieux cerner l
influence des micros perturbations
environnementales sur les conditions de
décomposition des cadavres on utilise
l'expérimentation en maîtrisant tous les
paramètres d'une inhumation on peut
observer en détail et sur le temps long
les conséquences du milieu sur les
charognes évidemment en france on
utilise des dépouilles l'animal a pour
avoir de vrais cadavres humains il faut
aller outre atlantique
près du centre médical de l'université
du tennessee il existe un terrain boisé
d'environ un hectare clôturée par des
barbelés à tout moment on peut y trouver
des dizaines de cadavres en train de
pourrir en plein air ou dans des coffres
de voiture c'est de cet endroit à éviter
pour les pique-niques que provient une
grande partie de nos connaissances
récentes sur la décomposition humaine on
l'appelle la ferme des corps en 1971 le
docteur williams basse et est souvent
sollicitée par la police pour des
affaires de meurtres mais faute
d'installations appropriées les
connaissances de l'époque était encore
très approximative quand il fallait
déterminer l'heure de la mort en tant
que directeur du département
d'anthropologie de l'université du
tennessee basse décida de combler cette
lacune en créant un complexe
spécialement dédié à l'étude de la
décomposition des cadavres c'est ainsi
que la première ferme des corps vit le
jour parmi les corps en question plus de
trois cent provenaient de personnes qui
en avaient fait dans la science en
disque d'autre n'avait simplement pas
été réclamé au bureau du médecin légiste
en étudiant sur les phases de
décomposition et notamment le cycle des
insectes basse ces étudiants ont permis
de faire progresser la médecine légale
et de résoudre de nombreux crimes il
existe aujourd'hui cette complexe de ce
type aux états unis régulièrement
visités par les agents du fbi haye et
parfois par des écrivains dans les
années 90 la romancière patricia
cornwell visite à la faculté
d'anthropologie du tennessee pour les
besoins d'un de ses livres qu un
intitulé body farm le surnom est resté
bref la prochaine fois que vous voudrez
planqué encore en espérant vous en
sortir n'oubliez pas qu'il ne faudra pas
seulement esquiver la police mais aussi
les archéologues
alors ce camping c'était sympa ouais
c'était cool après si vous étiez venu
avec moi franchement je me serais senti
un peu moins seul ah ouais pourquoi
parce que tu étais la seule boeuf non
mais disons que fred et l'est étaient
toujours ensemble et il parlait soit
spatiale ou de jeux ou de trucs bizarres
et mehdi on soigne observé de son côté m
soit il parlait en allemand avec les
c'était un peu exclu en attend mais il
parlait en allemand mais d'où il parle
en allemand bah on me dit l'habitant en
allemagne et les en suisse donc oui non
d'accord mais il parle français surtout
d'habitude c'est que super suspecte par
les allemands là j'ai bien que c'est
arte et tout mais quand même ça et quoi
il ya montée qui parle allemand aussi du
coup il va essayer de comprendre ce qui
mijote il va nous raconter parce que moi
ça m'intrigue cette histoire-là pas vous
un peu ça va quoi
[Musique]
si tu crois que c'est db
j'ai loupé ma bouche
il ya montée qui parle allemand aussi je
met là dessus il va nous expliquer un
peu ce qu'ils sont scott
un peu ça va quoi
[Musique]